john ganta was the winning pitcher april
24th gant is five and one lifetime
against the reds this will be his 20th
game and his second start
winker is baseball's best hitter against
right-handed pitching 369.
and that one is launched by winker
hammered into right center gone
15th homer for winker
and only the second allowed by gant all
year two nothing reds so runners at
second and third and now you have suarez
coming up great power hit his 13th home
run in game three yesterday
so one out and two on
and a ground ball orinato goes home
and the runner is hung up pisner will
tag him throw to second and it's a
double play
reds run right out of the inning wade
miley who has a no-hitter against the
cleveland indians to his credit this
year miley comes in five and four a 3.26
era tommy edmond leading things off
many of these cardinal hitters you see
their edmonds four for nine against
miley have hit miley fairly well but
good luck with that
there's a strikeout
carlson hitting 277.
swing at a miss back to back hayes for
wade miley
tyler o'neil batting 281 12 homers 27
knocked in one hop skip to the third
baseman suarez to his left field flip
flips to second to force out arenado
with india covering the inning is over
so miley does post scoreless first jesse
winker stands in
winker unloads again deep right field
he did it back-to-back plate appearances
with homers for winker
he clubs a three-run job and he has
driven in all five of the game's runs
matching his career high for homers
on june the 6th
shogu akayama is hitting for tyler
naquin here huh and the pitch
looped into left field falling quickly
and that's going to be a base hit so
shogo akiyama comes to the plate
and
picks himself up a base hit right out of
the chute
here's a eugenio swatters
first pitch and that's a base head into
left field
stevenson scores akiyama given the wave
o'neal from left throws in
cut off in the outfield grass two
run
base hit a eugenio suarez and the reds
are rolling in saint louis on sweep day
it's 7-0 and up comes mike freeman
suarez leads at second base
sosa plays behind him on the third base
side of second now on two and two
swing and a foul tip into kessner's mitt
strike three
the second strikeout for game two gone
and wade miley the pitcher is coming up
now against pitch miley hits it hard on
one hop to tommy edmond in short right
field the second baseman throws out
miley who made solid contact
shoguakiyama
he is in in center field
so hamstring tightness the official
designation for naiquin's removal
john gant hitless this year
riley is getting
just off the plate to right he's called
a strike
swing at the miss that is five
strikeouts for weed miley one down and
here's tommy edmond
the one two swing and a miss got him on
the cutter down and in back to back
punch outs
for wade miley two down he is struck out
for the last five hitters he's faced he
has six
already this afternoon
now nick castellanos who by the way
congratulations to nick castiano's today
his 1 thousandth game played
there's a lot of careers still to come
for this
dynamo
uzo for two trying to stretch baseball's
best hitting streak to 22 games
he's got the longest hit streak by a red
since 2007
one two
breaking ball hangs a bit that is
launched into fairly deep but playable
left center
and a swivel over the hips o'neal makes
the catch winker tags relay to second
tag is not there
jesse winker tagging advance
up to second to base two away
tyler stevenson is up
he has a walk
a single and a run scored
the reds have a seven nothing lead out
hitting the cardinals seven to two
winker got on with a walk and he
advanced on out number two a fly out by
castianos ground ball to the first
baseman goldsmith has it and wins the
race to the bag
no runs no hits a walk one left the reds
have stranded three here's tyler o'neill
with two on and nobody out
oh it's a hard foul
is scott barry okay our home plate
umpire
and it looks like he's going to be
relieved at home plate
that looks like dan iasonia
who is running in probably to put on the
home plate umpires equipment and give
barry the rest of the day off yeah i
hope he's all right
payoff pitch o'neil breaks his bat slow
roller to short flip to second one india
round to first not in time
kisner
a strikeout looking he's got the bases
loaded
but he's in a three for 16 slide with
seven strikeouts playing sparingly
behind yadier molina since the middle of
may
he is up to 77 pitches now the 1-1
swinging a slow chopper left side
it'll be fielded by suarez goes the
short way to india forcing out rondon
the inning is over and the cardinals
leave them loaded in the fourth back to
the top of the order and tommy edmond
first pitch swing fairly deep right
center castiano streaking back
oh sensational catch by nick castellanos
as he robs tommy edmond paul goldschmidt
is singled twice
miley a long look in has the sign and
deals the o2 goldschmidt swings and
misses fastball down and in eight
strikeouts for wade miley and he works
around the two out double gotta bring in
uh lead off man india
on one and two
gets the first strikeout of his major
league career on the outside corner
strikeout
of jonathan india
you mentioned it he's just pitching in
the zone around the zone
there's tyler o'neil over two couple of
the groundouts
the 1-1
o'neal
high drive into deep center field at the
wall
gone a long home run tyler o'neill
he's now driven in 29. 22 of his 40 hits
have been extra base hits this year
and matt carpenter with the bases loaded
475 the career average seven doubles
triple couple the grand slams his last
was last season at wrigley
86 runs batted in
here it
a comes fly ball and a deep right center
field and it is down one run in here
comes another carpenter to second he
drives in two
still nobody out runners at second and
third
here's tommy edmond
a shift here for tommy edmond and the
01.
little squibber off the glove of brock
run will score edmond is safe as they
throw it away
carpenter advancing to third and still
nobody out
nolan arnado
on base three times
head into center he's tied the game
nolan comes through
7-7
800th career run batted in for nolan
ornato
one out here's jesse winker winker has a
couple of home runs
reyes delivers and winker swings and
sends one high and deep to right field
going back on it rondon at the wall
leaps it's gone
winker's third home run of the game and
it puts the reds back on top
eight to seven
my goodness
and now
jose rondon up second and third two away
payoff pitch
swing and a miss ball lost barnhart's
got it
and the reds sweep the cardinals in st
louis
their first four-game broom cleaning at
busch stadium in over 30 years led by
jesse winker